this is a production of cornell
university
uh so
this is our fifth year of doing small
plot grain and fiber variety trials i
believe uh and
luis is a relatively new student in my
program pursuing his phd i think if you
were here last year you heard louise uh
talk about trials
uh
he's going to tell us about
the fiber plots that you're we're
standing in right here
and maybe a little bit about the dual
purpose plots that
don't look all that great
well thank you larry first of all who is
wearing hem fiber
that's disappointing
i am wearing one
100 hem fiber so with that in mind oh
youtube
so with that in mind i would like to
pass this around these are samples of
hemp
oh sorry these are samples of hemp fiber
and hemp herd so i would like for you
guys to take a look at it pretty much
this is what we will get from this field
after we harvest we read and we decorate
so as larry mentioned uh there is a
interest in the market for
uh fiber and grain production so we need
to find cultivars that can fulfill such
demand so one efficient way to do that
is with a small plot trials like the one
that you're seeing right now so here we
have 12 cultivars that are replicated in
four times in 30 square foot
area um we have five cultivars from
france and five cultures from china and
one cultivar that was developed by the
cornell breeding program
so um one thing that you know is that
well okay the
small plot trial will help you estimate
the yield right so that's great that can
help you fulfill a demand and great but
how about the quality and most
importantly what is quality right so one
important thing that we need to know is
how much of that can be uh used for
textile aka the best how much of that is
the herd right so if you have access to
a handout you can see on the back that
we have results from last year a street
trial if you were here and we observed
that some cultivars were able to develop
or to yield
about let me see compared to the
imperial system that would be
four point five to nine
us tons per acre if i'm not missing uh
and whereas others did not exceed 2.5
tons per acre right so there is a
considerable comparison across cultivars
now
um then we talk about yield and we have
to harvest then we let them read to a
specific point for a proper recordation
right and we observe that these high
yielding cultivars develop about two to
four uh metric tons per hectare which it
would be
one or
uh two us tons per acre uh so that's
that's pretty good right now the next
challenge is is it hot does it go hot
right so when we sample this we observe
that two of those high yielding
cultivars exceeded a 0.3 percent
thc threshold so that is very important
right because we can have a high
yielding cultivar but then your entire
field will be completely destroyed
because it exceeds the threshold so that
is one brilliant objective that we have
and we want to emphasize that you know
in this kind of outreach activities
right
so in the handout you can see the one of
the tools that we use for quality
assessment and that is the use of the
decorator uh in the back you can see the
machine that we use this was a machine
thanks to heather from lithuania that
helped us
decorate all this material
now
we talk about quality another important
um associated
agricultural practice
is the stand density
and that is that we need to ensure a
high planting density to
um have a thin stem because it is
believed that or what we have seen
actually is that the
lower the planting density the higher
the dignification in the stem which will
in turn uh mean that you have more herd
than bast in percentage right so why am
i saying this well this the target
planting density of this uh trial was
30 plants per square foot
however after three weeks of planting we
noticed um a strip of death as i like to
call it
a line perpendicular to the field was
after three weeks of after sorry two
weeks after planting we observed that
the plants were dying and slowly and
slowly so what happened was that we
applied this herbicide uh right after
planting
premature herbicide
and there was some overlapping in the
middle and when that happened uh there
was obviously a double application of
the earth this herbicide that um this
herbicide
whose active ingredient was
pentamethylene inhibits cell division
right so the symptoms of this are
sclerosis necrosis reduction understand
the stunt count obviously stunted growth
larry's pointing out to that
but in addition the plants that survive
had this bulbous
symptom at the base of the stem
so that is actually one of the symptoms
of the exposure to pendimetalling which
is the active ingredient of this
herbicide that we spray
so
there's something to keep in mind one
thing that we are realizing is that that
every side might not be as good because
our stunt count
is going down
uh
so we compensate for the poor seed
quality germination you name it but then
in the field we don't
we don't get that stun count so we see
that there is an extreme factor that we
were not considering and now we have to
consider which is the decimation of the
of the stem count by this herbicide
um
i have no time okay we're good
um yeah so in addition to that
we are also testing um the dual purpose
aspect of hemp or grain if you want to
call it as well so for that we
decreased the plant intensity
in this case was 12 plants per square
foot
and that you can see over there however
george already mentioned this
june was too wet we couldn't plant on
time and actually that plant that uh
part of the field was planted about a
month after this field uh however some
of them are looking pretty good and uh
one thing that will point out is that
there is another cultivar that we
developed in our program
that is planted over there and i am very
happy to say that this is a cultivar
that is thriving compared to the other
ones so
it's one of the culture it starts with a
gva
letter system and the other one will be
the same letter system right that are
actually on the north end of each plot
so please walk around look at the plants
don't kill them please i need to harvest
um uh and please uh you have any
questions
yeah for your seating rate why did you
choose the
like fiber typically is a heavier
planting density but why did you choose
these
this heavy of a planting density
um yes so the question was why did i
choose this heavy planting density for
these cultures so for this um
one thing that we were considering for
this was the percentage of emergence one
thing is having germination a paper
towel and quite another is having
germination in the field so we accounted
for seventy percent emergence uh use an
arbitrary number uh to
to have as much material in the field as
possible uh obviously top of the
material may be lost due to self
thinning if you guys are familiar with
that is the plants the culture itself
will uh shade out all the plants right
uh but the idea was to ensure as tight
planting density as possible to have the
greatest quality that we can get so
you can barely i mean
because you have the labels you can see
which cultivar is which but they are
very tightly planted and very close to
each other because we want to simulate a
fiber production system that will be a
larger scale
any other questions
what drills did you use
great question what drill did we use
we use a
oh jamie help me out um i think it was a
3.5
foot wide planter right
and i don't want to call the inner row
spacing was it 7 inch
seven and a half inch spacing drawers
oh sorry a cone theater yeah so the
consider facilitated us to actually
plant cultivar after cultivar in one
pass
any other questions about stem diameter
yeah so
last year when we were um
planting a strip trial i noticed a very
interesting interesting aspect of
the fiber hemp cultivars and that is
that certain fiber cultivars when
planted at lower densities
were pretty much trees they had a very
wide
stem diameter while other cultivars uh i
think european cultivars did not have
such wide stem diameter so here you can
see a decent stem diameter what is
collectively mentioned is a pencil thin
stem
for fiber right so like this would be
ideal but it's also ideal because we
planted a very you know
tight planting density
the
we did an analysis in regards to
correlation of a stand diameter with
bass sorry with
what was it
oh a sun count and stem diameter
so what we notice is that for some
cultivars the stunt count did affect the
stem diameter but for other cultivars
that wasn't so much the case so there is
some genotypic differences in the
response to plant intensity something
that we can explore and we can
definitely exploit
so if you're
if your harvest let me uh
uh
if you're going to harvest fiber for
textiles
this is the perfect size pencil diameter
that's what they want
uh that's going to maximize your
yield of high quality bass fiber
but
there are a lot of things we can do with
him
you may be more interested in the herd
for construction materials
or to mix in to make a bioplastic mix
and in that case you probably want to go
for the big plants
the big diameter plants because that's
going to maximize your herd yield
but
the bass fiber yield will
bass fiber quality will suffer in those
plants
and you also have to be able to harvest
it
so
my colleagues at north carolina state
have been working a lot with the chinese
cultivars
those tend to when they are in as louis
said when they're planted in low density
you tend to get big stem diameters
and they got you know one inch one and a
half inch even two inch diameter stems
at the base
which uh choked the sickle bar more
so you have to be able to harvest it
are you done all right are you moving on
to jamie sorry
um
how are you determining your harvesting
timing because when you're talking about
quality after it's been decorated
harvest timing is
how are you determining your harvesting
so the question is how do we determine
harvest time so
just to
add on to whatever larry said is that
this number not only affects harvest but
also the decoration you the curry gear
may be clogged where you have a
stem diameter that is wider than an inch
so it will be very difficult to remove
the bust so keep in mind so the harvest
time actually was based on flowering so
one interesting thing about flowering
i'm glad you asked this question is that
in some populations uh actually
population that we are going to harvest
for the demo we noticed that 15 about 15
of those individuals flower but that is
stopped
for like two weeks so
we can um
naively say oh let's flat this harvested
because it's flowering like that's the
optimal time point after that there's a
signification but no entire plot was
flowering so what we are doing is
estimating 50
of the individuals
flowering
for the harvest time once we reach that
point we can harvest the following week
so then we are sure that everything is
flowering and we can rule out
segregation in the population
and with that i would like to introduce
you jamie crawford
hello everyone
so we've planted our very first plot
trials for grain and fiber in 2017 so
this is actually our sixth year
sixth year pretty exciting
um and then in 2000 and for those trials
we harvested the plots with a small plot
elmeko combine
in 2019
we started in collaboration with
how many how many
other universities are involved in the
multi-state program
there are 14 other locations that are
planting the exact same trial as you see
down there
so you will see some
some cultivars that didn't do very well
here that may be outstanding in other
locations
so those are
university of vermont and michigan state
or some of the other northern locations
but then it's also at
it in
louisiana state
so we've got a huge difference
in latitudes for these cultivars
and so in 2019 we had a multi-state
trial and a trial that we managed the
way we always had and we did that again
in 2020 and throughout time
our trial methods became closer together
so now we just have the one trial that
we're managing all in the same way
the big difference i i think for
the management is before we would use
the plot combine like i mentioned for
the grain harvest
but well it's a very excellent combine
it the cutter bar is only able to go up
to two and a half to three feet from the
ground
so we weren't really able to give people
the dual purpose
information that they would like because
even the super tall culture bars
were cut off for grain at two and a half
to three feet
so
now everything is being harvested in
quadrats and we'll be able to give
everyone the fiber
yields that they would like as well as
the grain information
so
we'll walk through those on the way to
the next location so please
find me if you have any questions
oh i just want to mention
um there are some very excellent hemp
cultivars that look terrible
in the plot that we were going past so
that is um
yeah so the current conditions that you
see here are not representative of the
potential of those cultivars i want to
make that very clear
um
i think it was a combination of the
weather being planted the end of june
the herbicide may have had an impact
there were a few of them that were
marginal seed lots to begin with
and so um
lynn mentioned this morning if you were
in on her talk that uh
that if the seed lot wasn't great to
start then it was way more susceptible
to any of the herbicides so i think that
may have played a role in it
and at this hemp meeting last year i
i recommended anyone growing for grain
or fiber to do their own germ test
and so i've set up some ragdoll tests to
show you what you should see after two
days in the germ test and this these
were just in a ziploc bag in a sunny
window so it got an alternating warm and
cool temperature in the night and so at
the at the far end of this field i have
those set up so you can look and if you
find
that your seed lot looks a lot like the
bad one
then i you know i implore you reach out
to your seed provider so they can make
it right you do not want to put that in
the ground because even
if you have something with 40
germination um it's got other issues
than just low germination you cannot
increase that seeding rate enough to
make up for that low germ
and so yeah so
are there any questions before we start
walking um
sorry
can you just explain to the uninitiated
the ideal way of harvesting a green
purpose plant so that you're
maximizing both
um well
you'd want to harvest it when it's at
about 75 percent
the grain is
they turn it off
when the grain is about 75 percent
mature
and
i didn't think i pushed any buttons
when the grain's about 75 mature and you
want to raise the cutter bar up as high
as you can
so you can leave
both for the sake of your combine which
you don't want to
have all that material wrapping around
inside
and for the amount of fiber that you can
leave behind you want that cutter bar up
as high as you can to just take the seed
heads off
okay is that good
can i add on to that no yes please
so there are a couple of ways that you
can do a dual purpose harvest uh we have
a stripper header
from formation ag which they call clean
strip i believe
uh that we have mounted on the front of
the tractor where the bucket is
so we can raise that stripper header up
six or seven feet high
you can drive through the field and then
capture all of the grain from the grain
heads
and then we have followed behind that
with a sickle bar mower
and laid the
straw down
right behind the stripper header
so that's one way it's a two tractor
operation then
uh you have to be conscious of the
direction that you're going so the
sickle bar actually is going to come
back the opposite way that you went with
the stripper header because the stripper
header has sort of leaned the stems over
so we did that last year in some strip
trials that work quite well
that stripper header is then offloading
into a wagon you've got adjacent
the other way is to use a dedicated dual
purpose harvester there is a machine
that is a modified john deere combine
called built by the company hemp flax
we have one of those hemp flax
harvesters here in new york it was
brought here by canopy growth as a part
of their project a few years ago
uh if you're interested in doing dual
purpose hemp harvest
please come see me because we're trying
to retain that machine here in new york
uh to stimulate the hemp industry in new
york
and would like to identify people who
can commit to using that hemp flax
harvester in the future
so that we can make a business plan to
retain it here
uh the plan right now would be it would
it would be housed here at cornell
agritech
uh but it would be rented out on an
hourly basis
uh
so that the owners can recover the cost
of that machine
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu